m
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
mamma mia quoting a baby
[Music]
2 won't make you what fed you fasten
your seat belt straighten your
seat put your tablet away
because we're not going  delayed with
ralph please for once
can you clearer we go on the internet
[Music]
the welcome show on a quarter
of an hour
[Music]
hu
cool look at me all these things
new miracle I never  seen in all
my life
welcome to the search bar can
i help you find today
bubble bath midnight bread walkabout
names of cities names of countries non
of athletes classic crossbow artichokes
i have a feeling that  he's trying to
guess what you're going to say
autocomplete me is a little nervous these
days wait for the east find me a
website that rips a lot of
books for young people and only one result
no you know it's  cartoon characters
you gonna run away from me a little
[Music]
sally years because my daughters i'm a
trace chose and what kind of
princesses and you hide and bury magic
non humans are magic
no you talk with animals not
happy birds names  bewitched
have kidnapped sequestered at are you sure you're
ok or should i call the
police
is what people think all your
problems have been solved because a
strong and powerful man has come into your
life yes but when  it happens by the way
[Music]